[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec une actualité assez politique on va
parler des élections européennes on va
parler du sénat on va parler des hommes
politiques et des hommes d'état mais où
vas-tu retour en parler avec avec quatre
femmes que je suis ravi de recevoir and
perdriau bonjour bonjour vous êtes
conseiller régional ile-de-france et
vous êtes spécialiste et de
communication tout à fait et vous avez
organisé justement cette réunion sur
qu'est-ce que c'est la différence entre
l'homme politique noble et parce qu'on
est passé de l'homme d'état l'homme
politique vous en parlais tout à l'heure
ce film back log in bonjour vous êtes
membre de l'institut sapiens l'institut
sapiens se réfléchit un petit peu ce que
sera la société de demain et la nouvelle
place de l'homme surtout dans la danse
cette révolution qui a déjà commencé de
l'homme et de la femme
enfin quand on dit l'homme c'est l'homme
aux cent à jaden deidda gens fous je
suis maître de conférences à sciences po
et à l'université de droit et donc on va
parler avec vous justement politique
homme d'état on va parler sénart on va
parler des élections européennes et
coralie de dieu bonjour vous êtes avocat
préfère qu'on dise avocats et avocates
oui je ne vais pas la féminisation des
jeux je suis pas très favorable
on se voyait d'autres combats que la
féminisation surtout comme ça fait quand
même levé la seule profession où les
hommes portent des robes qui se féminise
plus que vous justement profitons-en
parce que c'est pas tous les jours que 4
femmes sur ce même plateau
est-ce que vous pensez que là il ya
encore une lutte à mener pour que la
place des femmes soient plus plus forte
plus grandes dents dans la société dans
les places importantes dans les médias
après moi je trouve qu'on a déjà fait
beaucoup de progrès il ya une libération
de la parole qui est très nouvelle on
parle beaucoup plus librement de sujets
ces mines amont par des règles notre
président de la république on a on a
parlé également lors d'un débat mais il
ya encore beaucoup de travail à faire on
est en france il ya encore des
différences de salaire considérable 10%
un poste à poste égal de différences de
salaires entre les hommes et les femmes
je crois que 16 % la moyenne en europe
donc on a encore du travail
parce que tu es là vous vous êtes un
cabrio est élu conseiller régional comme
iliad familiale à parité il ya la parité
à la fin ça y est mais je rejoins sofia
il ya une présidente exactement valérie
pécresse
mais je rejoins sophie sur le combat si
je puis dire qu'il doit se prolonger
comme je pense qu'on est qu'à 75 ans du
droit de vote pour les femmes ça
forcément il ya une inertie mais on a
déjà fait énormément de progrès mais il
faut tenir le cap et dans les médias
également on disait l'autre jour que 30%
du temps de parole dans les médias
donc c'était le dossard weldom
représenté par les femmes le temps de
parole des femmes comptent pour soral a
lu ce même mal à 20% des experts sur les
chaînes de télé 20% des experts donc
c'est des chiffres qui permettent de
s'engager pour continuer féminisé cette
profession qu'elle soit le progrès à
faire intervienne justement pas dans
l'art présente chez les enseignants il
ya une femme il ya des professions suis
avocat
enseignant non nous dans la fonction
publique voilà professeurs maîtres de
conférences ça va la féminisation tient
le cap on est même souvent plus de
femmes que d'hommes
mais je rejoins là encore ce qui a été
dit sur le combat à mener
évidemment on est au début d'envoi la
fin quand on voit notamment la
législation sur les violences faites aux
femmes les chiffres qui n'arrivent pas à
décroître dans l'union européenne c'est
le même combat
je crois qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
choses à faire même sur le plan
législatif
c'est vrai qu'on a parlé du coût de la
parité élective qui a été pendant
longtemps un camp un combat mené par le
législateur il ya des choses à faire sur
l'égalité plutôt salariale maintenant et
puis aussi sur l'égalité du traitement
des femmes avec cette question des
violences delà du harcèlement dru sur
sur lesquels on avance mais voilà il ya
encore des choses à faire que rallye des
dieux velroue une profession qui se la
justice et une provision qui s'est
féminisé beaucoup dans les dernières
années
alors oui c'est une profession qui
évidemment féminisé mais on a alors moi
je suis dans une partie droit des
affaires oui et donc cette partie là en
face exactement
et cette partie là et - féminisé c'est à
dire que vous avez beaucoup plus de
d'avocats collaboratrice
mais vous avez beaucoup moins en tant
qu'associé donc il ya ce fameux plafond
de verre qu'il faut et qu'il faut
exploser et là alors nous chez les
avocats nous sommes les moins biens les
moins bien traités parce qu'on a vu
qu'il y en avait des écarts de salaires
allant jusqu'à 50% avec les âmes donc
c'est énorme et c'est sont des sujets
qui sont vraiment traités actuellement
par le barreau c'est partout les
barreaux c'est ce sont des sujets qui
sont vraiment prévenant et qui avait
conclu longtemps et la mesure lui mais
ça tient à quoi pourquoi cette
différence parce que 50% c'est quand
même là c'est énorme je sais pas je sais
pas parce que comme vous dites c'est
plutôt des collaboratrices que yasi est
vraiment alors maintenant d'un rockeur
autant devant que je peux même plus
d'avocats phase ii commun ce couac et
dames
et on a on a vraiment cette espèce de
l'est de hiatus un clic et qui ne
s'explique pas et c'est vraiment très
difficile alors c'est encore plus
difficile dans les cabinets d'affaires
que dans les cabinets alors vous avez
des matières qui sont spécifiquement
masculine et des médias qui sont
spécifiquement féminine la patronne la
famille plutôt féminin féminin droit
social plus féminin également droit des
affaires plus masculin est alors quand
vous allez sur des matières beaucoup
plus technique de fusions acquisitions
de procédures collectives ou des choses
comme ça exactement non mais c'est donc
vous avez aimé ou qu on a à peu près le
même problème après ce que les
ingénieurs chez les ingénieurs
informatiques où il ya plus de
représentativité chez les hommes que
chez les explications qui était assez
incroyable quoi c'est à dire que pendant
les études les lélés les filles sont
meilleures que les garçons notamment
dans les matières scientifiques est
légal il me après quand il s'agit de
faire battu maths spé les grandes écoles
ont l'airé freiner c'est des mecs qui
prennent masse et les garçons ils
prennent la place parce que comme comme
si on est quand même encore dans cette
vidéo où il faudrait quand on est une
femme pour avoir moins d'ambitions quand
on a un garçon il ya peu encore sa coke
et qui est prégnant quoi je crois par le
gouvernement au moment de la journée de
la femme qui a un petit peu fait l'état
des lieux en disant notamment les deux
problèmes que tu pointes c'est à dire
que aux postes de responsabilité l'écart
est encore plus grand ça va jusqu'à 18%
donc c'est plus on évolue vers le haut
en fait que les femmes ont du mal un
petit peu à percer et non seulement
cette question des postes de
responsabilité mais aussi la place qui
était accordée à l'ambition féminines
c'est à dire essayer d'arriver à des
masculiniser certains certaines
professions ça c'est encore une
législation que beaucoup d'autres pays
de l'union européenne et que l'union
européenne elle-même promeut et que la
france n'a pas encore vraiment mise en
place mais essayer d'arriver à nos
plaques oiseaux nés des professions à
des sexes ça serait quand même encore
une évolution a mené je pense
énormément de valérie pécresse alors est
une forcenée de l'égalité hommes femmes
et notamment avec le centre hubertine
auclert où il ya énormément de d'action
très concrète alors que ce soit la
violence faite aux femmes l'égalité
hommes femmes etc
c'est vraiment un débat politique de
société extrêmement important mais
d'ailleurs puisque vous parlez de
politique il ya une sociaux qui s'est
créé dans les yvelines qui s'appelle ben
ali c'était les zébus des yvelines des
femmes des yvelines des quêtes allez
michel type de la sénatrice martens
idrac et de quelques femmes mères pour
inciter les femmes à entrer en politique
vous allez nous en parler après on
regarde le sujet puis on réagit ensuite
les yvelines sont le département qui
compte le monde famer dans la région
sonia breux au maire de saint cyr
l'école et à néry le pallec maire de
cheuvreux sont des exceptions
elles font partie de l'association elie
lancé ce matin dans le but de promouvoir
les femmes dans les yvelines qui
désirent s'investir pour le territoire
nous vraiment ce qu'on voudrait faire
partager c'est notre expérience de femme
et lui faire profiter des femmes qui
souhaiteraient s'engager qui ont des
hésitations des questions des
interrogations leur montrer que c'est
possible je reste persuadé que
le phare et l'orne sont complémentaires
là où je me pose question c'est sur le
le fait de devoir l'imposer pour que ça
devienne effectif face à ce manque de
femmes dans les effectifs des exécutifs
locaux comme à l'échelle nationale la
sénatrice martha de sidra qu'a lancé
elie l'association de promotion des
femmes en politique dans les yvelines
c'est tout simplement de permettre aux
femmes dose est d'aller plus loin dans
leurs ambitions parce que les femmes ont
également des ambitions et l'y
accompagnera également les élus dans
leur mandat et proposera à ses adhérents
des rencontres et des formations autour
des mandats politiques
on est toujours aux liens parce que
l'idée c'est de créer du réseau l'idée
c'est de créer du lien
cette association est également ouverte
aux hommes interpelle la secrétaire de
la délégation aux droits des femmes et à
l'égalité des chances entre les hommes
et les femmes
messieurs nous sommes à vos côtés et
nous avons autant de légitimité que vous
a aussi un moment donné nous saisir de
cet espace public
la cotisation à l'association elie et
d'un montant de 25 euros pour faire des
femmes mais ont retrouvé ce que vous
disiez un petit peu tout à l'heure dans
la politique notamment dans les deux
dans les yvelines c'est à dire que quand
même pas mal de femmes élues aussi on
regarde les députés par exemple joaquín
plus que nous parle d'homme mais
pourtant chez les mères c'est peut-être
un peu différent alors parce que c'est
une fonction peut-être particulière je
sais pas c'est une excellente idée
cette association parce qu'en fait
souvent on constate que sur le côté
pragmatique
les femmes sont plus engagés dans dans
le faire et en fait ce sont souvent des
élus extrêmement efficace qui quand
elles tiennent un sujet vont jusqu'au
bout
oui oui par contre marc thanos idrac a
raison de dire les hommes sont également
acceptés pourquoi le sang avait monté
les flammes
la question que voilà des internautes et
les intéressantes parce que on a fait
comme ça pour la parité est ce qu'il
faut imposer ou pas quoi c'est le
serveur est problème c'est un prend pas
ce qu'est ce qu'on attend que la société
fasse son travail
ou est-ce qu'il faut un peu active et
tout ça quoi et c'est un problème de
droit
d'ailleurs puisque finalement ça crée
une discrimination positive
alors certes en faveur des femmes mais
aussi en leur grand défaveur a à mon
avis puisque du coup ça fait primer la
kabylité du sexe sur la qualité des
mairies des talents au sens de l'article
6 de notre déclaration des droits de
l'homme et donc on a le sentiment que il
ya forcément une une forme
d'instrumentalisation du sexe à ce
moment là pour l'accès à la profession
c'est dommage d'en arriver là néanmoins
c'est une politique un peu américaine du
de la de arriver à l'égalité réelle en
bousculant un peu d'égalité de droits
est ce qu'on a encore besoin de ça
aujourd'hui tristement ça a l'air d'être
le cas
ça a bien marché pour la parité ça a
bien marché c'est bien marché et si on
l'avait si y'avait pas eu la loi je suis
pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui il ya autant de
femmes que d'hommes
pendant des années les parties ont
préféré payer les amendes d'ailleurs oui
oui absolument
culturellement enfin dallas bazin je
pense qu'il ya un travail de fond à
faire qui est dans l'éducation la
culture c'est que finalement les femmes
dès l'enfance au moins pousser à aller
vers certaines carrières
moi j'ai un exemple qui me marquent
toujours quand je vais à des débats
quand il ya les questions réponses à la
fin des hommes souvent se lève pose des
questions souvent il y en a pas en fait
ils ont quelque chose à dire les femmes
tu alors c'est vrai que j'ai passé sur
le sujet mais c'est quand même très
intéressant les femmes souvent avant de
poser leurs questions s'excuse à
l'avance alors j'ai peut-être pas bien
compris
j'ai pas toutes les compétences mais
c'est pareil en politique c'est à dire
que les meilleurs maintenant quand il a
demandé à certaines femmes si elle était
intéressée par une investiture potentiel
à terme les femmes répondent quasiment
systématiquement je n'ai pas les
compétences
alors que j'ai même pas sûr de toi pas
pour des généralisations mais la
majorité des hommes n'ont pas trop de
bouche c'est le temps même quand ils les
ont pas qu elle est drôle c'est vrai et
je pense qu'il ya aussi un phénomène
qu'on ne voit pas il y a le genre donc
le fait que l'on soit fan et le fait
qu'on ait des décès tribution familial
souvent oui ça on remarque que les
femmes interviennent plus haut plus
souvent tardivement dans des carrières
politiques
c'était avant et c'est peut être sûr de
sacrifices sur un nombre de devises non
faussée c'est compliqué aussi fort je
pense que ça doit pas être évident
d'être là fait danser des fusées pour
les hommes qui font ça parce que j'ai
une vie très prenante mais non non si en
vous écoutant je réfléchis aussi à 7
on parle beaucoup de la féminisation
mais ça va aussi de pair avec une
masculinisation de certaines fonctions
familiale justement on par mois du congé
paternité etc sur lequel pourtant la
législation là aussi mériterait
peut-être d'évoluer parce que pourquoi à
la femme la famille et à l'homme est
lancée
ni celle à qui j'ai relu encore un petit
peu l'écart yale on a beaucoup discuté
fin récemment maintenant c'est le sujet
est arrivée sur le tapis de la charge
mentale
il ya l'humain dans une prise de
conscience que c'est que cette charge
mentale c'est à dire il s'agit pas
simplement de faire ce qu'on vous
demande dans un dans un couple mais
d'avoir en tête toutes les choses à
prévoir qu'ils sont c'est un finish à la
liste des choses que j'étais en train de
faire l'histoire pour les enfants le
ménage et tout ça n'en finit pas et ça
prend une place absolument terrible donc
ça c'est que celle qui est maintenant ça
commence à s'équilibrer c'est qu'ils
avaient d'ailleurs quand même très
grande majorité fait parler toujours oui
statistiques mais je pense que dans les
jeunes couples à ça ça marche du trot
comme ça heureusement un pays où vous
avez organisé de cette es18 mastery une
table ronde
c'était à versailles ces tableaux ou
décrypter l'actualité le sujet de la
dernière table ronde était passionnant
puisque c'était homme d'état homme
politique lorsqu'on est passé d homme
d'état aux hommes politiques c'est à
dire de nom de de gaulle à maquereau ça
fait pourquoi c'est pourquoi ce que vous
avez choisi ce thème de la alors c'est
vrai que déjà on a souvent le
on pense souvent que quand on est élu en
fait les élus ne sont que des
gestionnaires et en fait les sujets de
société sont au coeur des missions des
élus donc c'est pour ça que cette table
ronde est né en partenariat avec la
région ile-de-france pour mettre sur la
table les sujets de société
alors le dernier de l'homme d'état à
l'homme politique
c'est simplement pour analyser le fait
que alors sur la vème république
on parle effectivement on est passé de
l'homme d'état dont qui incarne la
france donc je suis la france
ensuite je suis l'histoire de france
vidéo mitterrand plutôt à je suis moi en
fait
donc cette sorte de 2 d'évolution et de
la même façon on disait gouverner la
france dans un à l'époque de gaulle
après c'était gérer la cité avec giscard
etc etc et aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
piloter un business model donc voilà
rôle d'autorité
donc c'est un peu le décryptage 2 est de
7,2 cette évolution qu'est ce que pour
cette date sur ce passage là dessus
c'est compliqué aussi peut-être que la
politique c'est compliqué aussi
il fait des crises d'autorité qui a fait
donc les de confiance c'est vrai et ça
pose aussi toute la question la
définition de la politique parce que
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ça a été
beaucoup revaloriser on parle de
politique transformer la politique
moi je rejoins un petit peu cette
gestion de la cites c'est à dire que la
politique c'est la police
avec cette idée plus polis avec un s
c'est à dire cette idée que donc on a à
la fois la gestion de la police de
l'autorité mais aussi de l'incarnation
et bizarrement je n'ai pas forcément
certaines qu'on soit passé de l'homme
d'état à l'homme politique parce que je
crois encore que dans la posture récente
des manuels macron wiggum évoque son
dépassement si on peut se perdre
[Musique]
dépassement aussi de la figure partisane
et je crois que c'est aujourd'hui assez
importants notamment avec la crise que
nous sommes en train de vivre de
revaloriser un petit peu ce fait de
parler au nom de l'équipe élargie
j'ai le sentiment qu'on revient un petit
peu moi cette période où le peuple
français a besoin de s'incarner en tant
que peuple français quelles que soient
les clivages donc est ce que cette
évolution est aussi nets néanmoins sur
la manager manager réalisation cela fera
dix ans et demi c'est une réalité on la
ressent essayer de nos difficiles mais
la manager égalisation voyez c'est la
deuxième fois sa patte elle est réelle
aussi dans l'administration on a de plus
en plus 7
gérard pour voilà et on y est un site et
pas uniquement nous met notamment par
l'union européenne par les organisations
internationales
on gère aujourd'hui un état à la manière
d'une start up est ce que ça vaut pour
la fonction politique manger tendance un
petit peu à bien distinguer l'appareil
d'état et la fonction que ce président a
besoin d'incarner je pense que là dessus
on a encore besoin de l'homme politique
et que emmanuel macron est peut-être en
tout cas dans cette posture essaye de la
voix je sais d'accord avec toi moi
j'aime beaucoup cette citation de
churchill un politicien apprend on pense
à la prochaine élection
un homme d'état prend penser à la
prochaine génération
et c'est je pense qu'effectivement
emmanuel macron est plutôt dans cette
optique de penser à la prochaine
génération même si c'est pas forcément
les mages mais il donne alors il ya
peut-être la volonté des hommes
politiques donc pas l'écrit mais les
situations sont quand même très
différente dire qu'on fait pas de la
politique aujourd'hui comme on le
faisait en 58 ans 62 ans 65 du centre de
gaulle qui avait d'abord une autorité de
l'état qui était à l'époque sacralisé du
septennat surtout c'était l'époque du
septennat
il y avait une vision enfin le président
représenter autre chose était au dessus
là maintenant avec le quinquennat il
finalement l'élection présidentielle qui
courait qui coïncide avec les élections
législatives
on a finalement on est dans une
cinquième république est de plus en plus
présidentiel avec un président
républicain mais finalement c'est un peu
le ministre fondamentalement nous
gouvernent et n'est pas censé gouverner
il ya autre chose qui n'a pas aidé cela
c'est la doctrine sarkozy c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il a gardé la
présidence du parti
en plus de sa présidence de la
république et même avant avec de très
hautes fonctions qui étaient plus ou
moins une coutume on part avant de
lâcher la présidence du parti lorsqu'on
arrivait aux responsables hausse et
aujourd'hui on a une troisième aux
difficiles partisane isation cette fois
ci pas qu'une partie des nih vers cette
vème république puisque le chef d'état
est aussi le leader de son groupe et ça
à mon sens c'est un peu gênant encore
plus que le fait majoritaire qu'à créer
l'inversion du calendrier le quinquennat
on a présidentialiser mais on a en plus
rendu une couleur politique très
uniforme
d'où aujourd'hui la question du rôle du
sénat qui se valent et cette
particularité aujourd'hui que le premier
ministre n'est pas membre du parti
majoritaire en sièges de la majorité
bien un phénomène aussi qu'on ne peut
pas occulter
c'est le marketing politique c'est à
dire qu'à partir vous à partir de
communication à partir de 65
avec la campagne le canut et faut se
rappeler que de gaulle en fait hein
quand ça arrive est des états unis après
le débat nixon kennedy et c'est que les
médias avaient fait leurs preuves aux
états unis de gaulle a refusé parce
qu'il disait qu'il n'était pas un
produit un coup il était justement un
homme d'état qui n'était pas un produit
et donc du coup l'agent de michel
bongrand s'est tourné vers le cabinet
est donc cette amorce virage essentiel
dans la politique qui a fait que les
politiques ont pensé à communication
avant évidemment le programme et etc
est ce vrai que vous avez raison c'est
devenu le premier américanisé comme on
disait là la bri il y avait d iran 65 à
un épisode assez intéressant c'est que
pendant toute la campagne de premier
tour il ya une campagne officielle il
est candidat
de gaulle n'avait pas participé non
ouais c'est la reprise pour les deux
tours à l'attraper mais le canut et en
quinze jours est passé de 2 % à 15 %
c'est vrai que c'est de la décence et la
naissance de la communication devant
marketing politique en france et alors
ça vous me posiez aussi une autre
question dans cette table au monde c est
ce qu on peut tenir aujourd'hui un
discours de droite et un discours de
gauche
là c'était une des questions qui étaient
posées tout à fait tout à fait alors
évidemment on s'est dit est ce que la
droite et la gauche aujourd'hui c'est
progressiste et populiste mais je pense
que ça va ça va au-delà de ce clivage
progressiste populiste c'est ce que vous
disiez le livre d'ici là les deux
collaborateurs ex-collaborateurs
puisqu'ils ont quitté l'elysée pour
parler de des bénévoles macro oui je
sais que le sujet était intéressant et
10 dans leur livraison de phrase que
j'ai pas exactement mais rappelez les
auteurs mais pardon amiel et aimé l'idée
mais on se l'était bien qu'ils étaient
donc collaborateurs des médias
exactement et en fait ils disent vont
eux leur vision c'est que finalement la
gauche la gauche a trahi puisque au delà
de faire un trait d'égalité
finalement parce que les espèces de
corporatisme se sont installés un droit
du travail qui est devenu très compliqué
finalement qui ne protège que ceux qui
ont un travail entre autres et la droite
a travaillé la liberté puisque
finalement au lieu d'aider les
entreprises ou les personnes qui
travaillent finalement reste figé à
protéger des acquis et et surtout non
comme électeurs maintenant qui
essentiellement des personnes de plus de
50 ans je crois que 10 % 10 % seulement
des moins de 50 ans ont voté pour le
candidat de la droite classique aux
élections présidentielles les nouveaux
taux de votre contrôle mais plutôt le
pen sur l'électorat est assez partagée
on a du mal à avoir une véritable
constante au niveau des lectorats des
jeunes ça va vers l'écologie ça peut
aller vers le discours un petit peu plus
renouveler comme le en marche au moment
l'élection présidentielle ça pose à mon
avis tous conflits de l'offre politique
en ce moment c'est à dire que le parti
les verts
n'existe plus vraiment tous les partis
traditionnels auxquels on avait
l'habitude de voilà qu'on avait
l'habitude de voir qui travaillent avec
nous sont un petit peu disparu
aujourd'hui en tout cas en termes de
légitimité et la question du discours de
droite et de gauche je suis pas sûr
qu'elle soit encore d'actualité parce
que justement toutes les problématiques
dont dont vous parliez des populistes
progressisme europe écologie etc sont
devenus aujourd'hui des combats communs
donc c'est très difficile de renouveler
des clivages aussi ancien que le
libéralisme contre le socialisme ccc
beaucoup moins réelle
et je crois que cette évolution de ce
qui est rassurant là aussi c'est que
c'est pas une évolution simplement
française bien au contraire tous les
partis s'effondre dans l'europe dans la
vieille europe précisément parce que il
ya une universalisation 4e qui arrivent
des combats sous influence de l'union
européenne est sous l'influencé aussi
d'une évolution des mentalités c'est à
dire que tout est devenu un combat
commun aujourd'hui alors l'état les ans
et qu'on revient à nouveau à la campagne
de 65
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de parallèles
entre 65 et 2010 est bizarrement et où
de gaulle avait déjà
parler de cette idée d'être au dessus
des partis
c'est cette chute et c'était là il sa
grande théorie et donc on dit les
manuels macabre et vous parlez pas que
la politique c'est vrai mais c'est
beaucoup inspiré de la campagne de
choisir sûr parce que en marche c'était
aussi le slogan de jean le camus et
indien c'était amusant et c'est pour ça
que le parallèle 65 2017 a été fait sur
ces lahmaza semaine la version parce que
c'est pas vous parallèle auquel on note
comparer beaucoup le pourtant c'est vrai
qu'il ya d'autres points de lyon mais
d'étendre la naissance de la gauche qui
est ce qui est quand même très
différente en 65 matchs et c'est vrai
mais de nuire au parti présidentiel ça
c'est un parallèle compense pas souvent
à faire mais emmanuel macron a été l'un
des premiers présidents être élu avec un
parti qui n'a existé que par lui
quelques mois auparavant avec de gaulle
en 65 puisque précisément cela c'est lui
en 58 le général qui a fait partie de
toutes pièces pour ne pas faire de
l'histoire en lice et c'est ce que sa
famille ne sont pas plus à giscard
alors j 16 ans 14 parce que gesca est
élu avec sans parti pratiquement falla
républicains indépendants ces petits
partis et justement il fait campagne en
dehors des partis en france 2 c'est par
son parti qu'il fait lire ça sur deux
deux français sur trois c'est vrai qu'il
ya de parallèle à mon avis qu'ils
méritent d'être faits c'est que je sais
car il ya d'abord cette figure de
l'homme à ces jeunes qui prendra donc il
ya beaucoup de parallèles à faire avec
emmanuel macron notamment aussi et
surtout en persan triste parce que c'est
la première fois qu'elle centre et la
parole centriste en politique néanmoins
le parallèle que je faisais avec le
parti gaulliste c'est que quand il est
arrivé en 58 et en 65
le général de gaulle avait constitué un
parti autour de sa personne c'est à dire
un parti
les premiers partis de personnalisation
en fait ce qui est un petit peu moins le
cas de la parti de godillots
exactement et c'est un peu la même chose
avec le en marche c'est à dire que c'est
autour de la personne qu'on crée le
parti ce qui est un petit peu moins vrai
que pour giscard qui lui se fondait sur
la ligne du milieu en quelque sorte
emmanuel macron a fait les deux un parti
sur sa personne et au milieu du conflit
bras gauche un parti anti parti qui est
devenu un parti et ça c'est la mode saas
et la mode c'est la mode en grèce en
italie
voilà tous les partis anti partisans ont
la cote alors parler de droite et moi
que koivu lui c'était que je parlais
justement droite et de gauche de disco
de droite et de gauche et si on si on
regarde les élections européennes au
fond on s'aperçoit quand même que le
vrai clivage enfin le clivage qui mars
et les images progressiste populiste
c'est puisque les deux les sourds d'âge
vont évoluer parce que là pour l'instant
les sondages sont faits sur une campagne
qui n'a pas commencé donc c'est un peu
compliqué sont donc c'est plutôt sur des
critères de politique intérieure mais on
voit que la liste est le r alis
renaissance elle s'appelle serait en
tête suivi de prés ou deux après prépa
la liste du rassemblement national un
peu d'effondrement quand même deux de la
liste républicaine gros effondrements
de l'élite des insoumis et avec vous
font à peu près le même écart qu'au
premier tour des présidentielles entre
la liste en gros mc well as le pen quoi
c'est quand même intéressant c'est
intéressant et à mon avis c'est l'une
des spécificités de ce scrutin que celui
des élections européennes dans le sens
où on dit très souvent malheureusement
l'argument européen aujourd'hui n'a plus
cours et on fait de la politique
intérieure
ça n'est pas faux néanmoins on l'a fait
à l'aune de ce qu'on veut pour l'union
et c'est là que se cristallisent
l'attention pro union ou contrat union
et c'est finalement cette fameuse
querelle populistes comme progressiste
parce que ceux d'il ya deux positions
qu'ils soient là il ya deux positions
claires c'est le cas dans tous les états
c'est le cas dans tous les états est-ce
qu'on veut plus d'europe pour est-ce
qu'on en veut moi c'est la question
là il ya une interview de franck ribéry
mines dans le point et on voit vous de
commenter mais on voit bien qu'il ya
déjà des paragraphes sur lesquels il est
plutôt proche de macron d'autres proches
de marine le pen donc des positions sont
pas claires chez des insoumis c'est
exactement pas il fouilla il ya des pro
européens et puis il ya des
nationalistes donc c'est vrai qu'une
prime à la clarté qua non non moi je
considère que toute façon enfin la liste
l air à mon sens il n'y a pas de projet
je vois pas je vois pas très bien ce
qu'ils proposent par contre à mon sens
n'a pas on n'a pas d'autre choix que de
vouloir une europe plus forte par
rapport aux vis-à-vis des deux grandes
puissances
n'auront pas d'autre choix que d'être
unis et ce qui est dommage c'est qu'il
ya une vision qui est très différente
je lisais le livre d' ivan krastev le
déclin de l'europe entre les pays
d'europe de l'est et les pays d'europe
de l'ouest culturellement on pense pas
du tout la même chose
ils ont vécu l'explosion voit la suite
au communisme donc ils ont à la fois
besoin et envie d'europe et en même
temps il l'a craignent donc une espèce
de paradoxe aussi qui est à régler en
interne mais bon je crois qu'on doit
tous comprendre que que face aux chinois
quand on voit que la nouvelle
agglomération la de pékin je ne sais
plus quel était le chiffre c'est 100
millions d'habitants où on est on est 60
en france il faut juste se rencontrer
unis on a enfin plus fort un peu brisé
alors vous êtes de conseiller régional
elle est restée dix week-ends pendant
peut-être pas regarder mais vous pouvez
comme peut-être défaut dans la liste moi
j'ai un avis tout à fait notamment
inverse à sophie 1 c'est clair pour pour
plusieurs raisons je trouve qu'on peut
pas fonctionner dans une démocratie et
la démocratie française a fortiori en
ayant un pôle
pour un pôle contre un pôle bon impôt le
méchant etc
c'est impossible donc en fait pour cette
première raison la deuxième raison pour
moi françois xavier bellamy a été au
début j'étais un petit peu interrogative
c'est un garçon brillant qui copie ici
parce qu'il vient souvent qui tire
vraiment le débat vers le haut et que ça
fait du bien de réécouter en fait un
débat politique où on a l'impression que
ça fait des années que j'ai l'impression
en écoutant un débat politique que je
n'apprends rien que c'est des joutes de
communication ou et c'est avec
françois-xavier mélanie c'est vrai que
on a l'impression a contrario qui a un
vrai projet qui a un vrai un vrai débat
et qui repositionne aussi avec beaucoup
de sérénité ça aussi on en a beaucoup
besoin en politique il calme un petit
peu le jeu de l'hystérisation permanente
de la politique et ils reposent les
problèmes au bon endroit et le trio de
tête pour moi est un trio extrêmement
intéressant et constructif
puisqu'il ya agnès evren en deux et en 3
donc arnaud grandjean qui est un
centriste
et c'est vrai que de l'europe
très sincèrement alors que j'étais très
tiède au départ en me disant bon et
c'est là la jeu oui je démontrais
favresse bel abbès le disait un peu
sophie c'est vrai que c'est peut-être
pour ça que la liste un petit peu de mal
à prendre leçon je sais que la position
des pas très clair à ce que c'est très
pro européens ou pas très européen ça
dépend des sujets celle des pans il faut
bien il faut bien il faut bien qu'ils
aient il essaye de capter tout leur
électorat donc il ya des souverainistes
et il ya des européens dans le décor à l
air non non non c'est un projet pro
européen et après pro européens mais pas
n'importe comment
tous ces problèmes avec l'union
européenne c'est que finalement comme tu
le disais il ya cette idée d'être en
commun il ya un hymne national de
l'union européenne ya plein de belles
valeurs il ya l'erasmus qui fonctionne
bien néanmoins ça pose la question du
choix de la souveraineté et beaucoup
d'états réalise
on le voit avec l'exemple du brésil que
finalement se défaire de l'union
européenne devient beaucoup moins facile
que d'y entrer et aujourd'hui la
question que posent les parties
complètement nationaliste elle est quand
même intéressante pour le débat
notamment pour apprendre ou non aux
électeurs si on peut vraiment sortir de
l'union et je pense que ce qui
cristallise un petit peu les passions et
les angoisses
c'est est ce que l'union européenne est
devenue une espèce de big world ou cette
technocratie nous mange tous et qu'on ne
peut plus décider et c'est qu'on peut
plus en sortir parce que finalement il
ya des il ya des ramifications partout
où est ce que c'est encore un choix
politique et je pense que vraiment le
parti qui réussira à réunir derrière
miss est celui qui démontrera qu'on a
encore le choix et que ce choix c'est un
choix politique plein et entier et voilà
et assumer alors technocratique comme
toujours appelé qui a moins de
fonctionnaires à bruxelles que anomalie
oui je ferai juste me débats de la
souveraineté là je me positionnerai
juste sur l'aspect juridique c'est qu'en
fait on est souverain dans l'europe en
fait les pays africains il ya des
traités on a signé des traités on a
transféré des compétences
l'europe est titulaire seulement deux
compétences avait pas titulaires de
fonctions les fonctions s'il nous qui
les exerçons donc et a donc les états
les peuples soient encore souverainiste
donc cette dichotomie entre on est
souverainiste on est européen pour moi
est une hérésie absolue on a transféré
des compétences
donc l'europe c'est juste on se met
d'accord parce qu'on se dit qu'à
plusieurs on est quand même vachement
plus fort que quand on est tout seul et
on est sûr certaines compétences on
assure on en a fait schengen schengen à
la base c'est un traité multilatéral qui
a été ensuite intégré dans l'europe
on a fait la liberté de circulation des
personnes c'est quand même fantastique
de pouvoir se dire que on va aller dans
un pays on a juste besoin de sa carte
d'identité
on n'a pas besoin d'un visa on n'a pas
besoin de payer c'est vraiment bien
on peut acheter un autre produit dans un
pays européen il ya vraiment on peut
aller ouvrir un compte bancaire dans un
autre pays on a quand même cette union
que l'on que l'on regarde et c'est ce
qui avait complètement perdu pour moi le
brésil
et c'est là où après ils sont en train
de réaliser à quel point on est imbriqué
et à quel point on est interdépendant en
fait le break 6 et une interdépendance
c'est à dire qu'on a des gens qui sont
dit à bastien en fait on est tout seul
on est bien notre côté et il n'y a que
nous ils s'aperçoivent qu'on fait on est
tous interconnectés et là on pourrait
basculer sur la sur la taxe gaffe parce
que on est dans une année dans une multi
enfin on est plusieurs
alors quand j'ai donné mon compliqué
d'évoquer volet c'est la latéralisation
qui arrive très bien mais en fait on est
vraiment dans un monde global hyper
connectés et déjà on connaissait au 19e
siècle il y avait il y avait une très
forte mondialisation il ya une
mondialisation absolue on avait quand
même en chine au japon alors qu'elle
était quand même d'aider des pays qui
était éminemment éminemment fermé qui
n'accueillait pas beaucoup d'étrangers
et pourtant il est allé donc la
mondialisation a toujours existé
simplement là pour l'europe je pense que
le débat souverainiste et et et
progressistes pour moi est un faux débat
et là on revient sûr sûr sûr du
marketing parce que c'est complètement
d'un point de vue en tout cas
institutionnels c'est inexact mais après
il ya des tendances au populisme et au
repli quand même et c'est même assez
frappant c'est à dire que si vous
regardez c'est souvent les anglo saxons
nous précèdent mais dans les années 80
il est hatcher igad qui ont amené le
libéralisme est aujourd'hui quand vous
regardez l'angleterre c'est le brésil et
l'amérique se trompe donc c'est
peut-être aussi ce qui nous guette c'est
surtout que j'apporterai un tout petit
bémol sur la souveraineté je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec toi on crystallis
finalement des positions on diabolise un
petit peu le débat je pense que c'est
aussi un petit peu but malheureusement
là aussi pour des raisons de
communication
néanmoins sur la perte de souveraineté
je crois quand même con qu'on peut
affirmer qu'elle est réelle et justement
là aussi ça fait le pont avec la thèse
cafard c'est qu'en matière financière et
monétaire on est quand même tellement
interdépendants que c'est ça qui sert
aussi les partis anti européens pour
dire qu' on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
être complètement
souverains notamment au niveau de la
gestion de notre dette dont on part sans
cesse et on a le sentiment que nos
politiques se cache un petit peu aussi
derrière cet argument et je pense que
c'est eux qui desservent l'union
européenne parce que du coup à force de
dire que à cause de leur gestion de la
finance et que ça se décide à bruxelles
on en arrive à haas 17e se
déresponsabiliser et je crois que c'est
vraiment un petit peu ça le problème
c'est que il ya quand même beaucoup de
choses qui concernent directement la
souveraineté des états qui se décide à
bruxelles mais ça reste du domaine du
choix politique nationale néanmoins on
l'assumé de moins en moins je pense que
c'est vraiment cela prouve que c'est ça
c'est que je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on a ce qu'on
négocie à bruxelles c'est l'expression
des états non mais après on dise à la
bourse de bruxelles mais c'est laisser
passer les états ou leur pouvoir les
gouvernements alors pouvoir
inside et font souvent leurs propres
intérêts nationaux voilà en tout cas vos
quatre avocats pardon
riskalis est ce que vous sentez déjà
dans les entreprises des conséquences de
brigitte hamada sont tout m'a déjà vous
avez les douanes
les douanes françaises qu'on ait mis un
papier en dix ans
on se prépare vous avez un break zik
vous avez un portail vers exit qui a été
oubliée non c'est pas enfin si on sait
enfin il faut tout détricoter et en fait
on va on va traiter le pour l'instant on
est dans la version no deal etc on
traite on traite le uk comme si c'était
un état tiers et on traitait avec avec
les états unis où ou le venezuela ou des
choses comme ça on est vraiment avec un
état complètement tiens on n'a jamais
rien eu avec eux ils sont juste son
justin du côté de la manche là mais
c'est messi c'est tout c'est et pour
l'instant tout a été préparé pour
et on remet les barrières quoi on remet
les douaniers donc vous avez vous avez
des douaniers qui savent tellement pas
ce qu'ils vont devenir que ils font la
grève du il faut une grève du zèle donc
ça vous avait des lignes d'aidé que
phénoménal ce qui bloque aussi les
entreprises parce que vous avez les
entreprises qui attendent des produits
qui ne sont pas livrés et puis c'est
vrai que en houle et quand on a des
choix à compter des entreprises par
exemple le choix prix mais a pris dans
une structuration c'est qu'une boîte
américaine passée peu ou prou toujours
par le uk pour pouvoir parce qu'il y
avait il ya une connexion en terme de
langage et après aller dans la zone
europe
maintenant on peut plus a fait ça fait
déjà trois ans déjà quand il en a
commencé à parler du breakbeat
on propose même plus la structuration
vielle du look et parce que même à
mettre un but digne instar de celle de
plus la baule mais non mais c'est
surtout qu'en fait pour
pour les chiffres pour les personnes qui
veulent investir il faut de là il faut
de la stabilité ce que notre fiscalité
n'offrent pas et alors on est très
inventif qu'on a besoin d'argent est
très inventif et on offre pas de
stabilité et on en est même tenté si
bien à dire nous avocats
mais on va vous aider joue parlementaire
au gouvernement parce que on est les
premiers confrontés parfois on ne sait
même pas interpréter un texte dire qu'on
est là un outil bits donc quoi
parle-t-on et il ya des parfois il ya
des gadgets des thèmes aussi pumba là on
va interpréter ça mais vous allez
trouver autant d'avocats fiscalistes que
d'interprétation du texte alors après
vous avez des positions dominantes mais
on a vraiment une instabilité et donc
qui est très préoccupante parce qu'on se
priva on se prive on se prive de
personnes qui voudraient investir chez
nous parce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler qu'on a une très bonne force de
travail on a des gens qui sont bien
éduqués
on est quand même les plus productives
visto monde on a plein de qualités on a
une bonne qualité de chercheurs
d'universités donc la france vraiment
énormément d'atouts ne serait pas la
sixième puissance mondiale si on était
si on était vraiment sis à la rue que ça
et en même temps avec cette insécurité
vraiment fiscale
on dépasse on n'arrive pas à se tirer un
peu des balles dans le pied et d'autres
avoir justement une politique européenne
de la fiscalité aux meilleurs ça fait 20
ans et après l'europe fonctionne sur
l'unanimité c'est là que vous devez vous
de mettre tous les états à tout le monde
d'accord mais on doit mettre tout le
monde d'accord
ce qui lui passe qu'on ait dit justement
c'est pour l'une des rares espoirs de
l'europe justement n'est peut-être que
l'idée c'est d'avoir de l'europe à deux
vitesses dont on parle depuis depuis
longtemps puisque vous parliez des
débats parlons maintenant de la taxation
des gaffes à qui veux tu veux expliquer
l il ya un projet de deux français
voulez-vous expliqué sophie la situe
sapiens on a on a sorti il est une étude
sur la taxe gaffe a donc effectivement
un projet français de taxation peut dire
ce qu'on veut
oui donc oui pardon les amazon facebook
j'oublie toujours le dernier apple voilà
le projet français de la france a décidé
de faire cavalier seul là dessus puisque
l' ocde
depuis janvier est en train d'étudier
trois possibilité de taxer les gaffes à
la france pour moi c'est une mesure
politicienne mais avant un temps d
avance
parce que l'idée c'est quand même quoi
c'est qu'ils font des bénéfices et ils
payent pas d'impôts il est complètement
normal de payer des impôts quand on fait
des bénéfices
après donc la france fait cavalier seul
a décidé de créer sa propre taxe cafards
et donc bruno le maire a fait une
proposition qui est de taxer à 3% le
chiffre d'affaires moi je l'aimé le
suive un sujet que le chiffre d'affaires
évidemment parce que le chiffre
d'affaires ça veut tout et rien dire
puisque c'est pas le bénéfice donc 300
euros voilà ça peut ça peut représenter
30% du bénéfice de l'entreprise donc
c'est énorme
donc finalement
notre notre impression c'est que ça va
finalement pénalisé les entreprises
françaises ça va représenter une goutte
d'eau dans le tonneau des danaïdes qui
les entreprises font ça parce que plus
une société comme blaquart criteo
leboncoin cdiscount trois pays se rêve
lorsqu'on débit de sousse qui sont ceux
qui s'étaient pas que les gars donc non
ça c'est pas que les gaffes en fait
c'est ça s'appelle taxact femme aimée à
tort et oui c'est ça c'est beaucoup plus
lorsqu'il faut arriver à dire c'est
justement la spécificité dégâts face et
pas uniquement de faire d énormes
bénéfices ou c'est peut-être les quatre
entreprises qu'on connaît le plus
aujourd'hui mais c'est surtout il y en a
plein d'autres
c'est surtout que ce sont des
entreprises du numérique et c'est très
difficile d'arriver à fiscaliser
justement les entreprises du numérique
parce qu'elle fait elles n'ont aucune
obligation de résidence vous prenez les
quatre elles peuvent totalement ce
s'investir dans un cloud qui existe dans
l'ue ne voilà donc ce qu'elles font et
donc aujourd'hui arrivé à l'euro oblige
et finalement les obliger les humains
finalement je ne parle plus français à
arriver à les obliger à implanter leurs
bénéfices dans un état plus que dans un
autre c'est déjà une forme de cruauté au
niveau de leur fonctionnement et en plus
leur dire de l'installer vous craint
c'est une forme de justice fiscale mais
il faut comprendre que dans leur
raisonnement à eux c'est purement
factice c'est à dire leur demander
d'avoir des établissements stables en
france pour eux ça ne leur sert à rien
c'est contre-productif et ça ne
représente pas la majorité de leurs
activités donc c'est très difficile
d'arriver alors à les obliger à faire
cela et en plus de leur expliquer venez
en france parce que c'est là que vous
vendez plus mais néanmoins c'est là que
notre fiscalité des sociétés et presque
la plus chère pourquoi ne pas
s'installer en israël
et cette fois sont donc la logique elle
est assez difficile à imposer même si
évidemment qui essaie d'être acceptée
mondiale ça serait beaucoup plus facile
maintenant il faut bien qu est peut-être
quelqu'un qui actionne la boucle on
exactement ça va finir comme la taxe la
taxe air france réinventée par notre ami
chirac
j'étais l'idée c'était justement de
servir de locomotive aux autres pays
européens sont évidemment personne n'a
suivi
d'où le nom maintenant taxe air france
n'avait pas besoin de ça en plus
le contextualiser tout ça c'est qu'on a
on a des entreprises qui fonctionnait
dans le numérique donc le numérique qui
a pas de barrière la frontière n'existe
pas donc on a on à cette problématique
là donc effectivement comme tu le disais
elles sont dans un dans un schéma de
pensée qui est totalement différent
c'est la frontière que ça n'existe pas
après elles sont sont des entreprises
qui sont extrêmement bien aux
conseillers ont joué et là c'est là où
il les états essaye de se mettre de cinq
heures de marche pas pas du tout c'est
qu'elle elle joue
elles jouent complètement avec les
différentes juridictions
donc déjà les juridictions vous allez
dans un pays où dans ce sens d'autres
vous n'avez pas forcément avoir la même
définition pour parfois vous allez avoir
un intérêt et un autre qui va être qui
va être du dividende
quand vous jouez sur les deux
vous êtes vraiment vous pouvez vraiment
faire une très forte optimisation donc
il ya déjà il ya de l'optimisation qu'il
faut recontextualiser le problème c'est
un problème qui existe ça fait au moins
trente ans
que on a dit qu'il y avait un problème
sur le numérique est resté un rapport
ton quant aux écoles
colin à colin donc qui ont dit un
établissement stable numérique qu'il
faut vraiment recontextualiser on a des
entreprises qui fonctionnent en dehors
de tout espace de frontières donc en
fait vous voulez passer c'est le monde
certains médias lisation dans combien ça
fait quand même le fait que l'entreprise
fait des bénéfices ne paye pas d'impôts
mais n'en voyez bien en france mais sans
paye quelque part très peu oui mais elle
en fait la barbe aux autres entreprises
mais ça je dis pas le contraire je vous
dis juste que la faction dont les choses
se sont faites en fait il ya une
problématique d'appréhension fiscale de
ce flux le flux il existe on s'en fout
c'est on le connaît tous le connaît
enfin en fonctionnant règles de
fiscalité internationale a fait ce qui
était international s'est associé des
nations c'est ça plus d'un siècle c'est
pas du tout c'était les flux physiques
maintenant on n'est pas des choses
complètement dématérialisé donc on a
l'eau ces deux cas et miss et son
rapport qui héberge ce qui est sur
l'érosion la lutte contre l'érosion des
bases fiscales
vous avez l'union européenne qui
travaille également la france
conjointement avec l'allemagne avait
proposé une taxe une taxe de 3% chiffre
d'affaires l'allemagne c'est un peu
désolidariser des pour des
problématiques de politique intérieure
et vous avez d'autres des états la
france n'est pas tout seul vous avez
d'autres états qui sont qui réfléchit
vous avez de l'italie vous avez
l'espagne je crois qu'il ya là la
pologne quelque chose au dail à peu près
six états européens qui réfléchissent on
est simplement les premiers à avoir tiré
en mai et dans la proposition européenne
y avait deux propositions lire et une
proposition intermédiaire qui était de
10 rebonds à combler 3% c'est que c'est
pourri mais en tout cas on met en
intermédiaire parce que après on va
rentrer en marche
coordonner avec l' ocde
on a un phénomène assez impressionnant
c'est que l' ocde on a enfin les états
unis qu'on n'avait pas avec barack obama
on atonale tram donc pour le prêt plus
tôt
trump et notamment pour trame quand il a
fait sa réforme fiscale
pourquoi on ad on a des boîtes on a des
cages box qui sont dans l'est qui sont
donnés dans les pays à fiscalité parce
que nous on appelle privilégiés qui sont
faites des paradis fiscaux est en fait
y'a des caches box google apple a un
trésor de guerre de 500 millions planqué
dans les bahamas
sauf que quand vous rapatrier l'argent
aux etats unis c'est 35 % d'impôt a
partiellement voix rapatrier donc en
fait ils ont tout un système où ils
remontent tous l'argent peu ou prou en
passant très fréquemment par les pays
bas qu'on appelle le sandwich
néerlandais est donc vous remontez tout
comme eux
ces trafics civilisation non mais ce que
je vous ai dit c'est que s'il ya une
grosse optimisation se dire qu on joue
sur l'existence et pas des gens qui
feront connaître elle est quand même là
la volonté de deux de règlementer de
moraliser sinon à brioude
alors moi je réagissais c'est marrant en
termes de communication et je me disais
cette question c'est typiquement
l'exemple de questions de comme
extrêmement mauvaise pour un référendum
etes-vous pourquoi la version 99.99 %
pour bien sûr bien sûr alors que vous
expliquer très bien certaines choses
mais que la majorité des gens me dis que
c'est pas parce qu'une chose est
difficile à faire qu'il veut mais on en
fait surtout monde est d'accord sur le
fait que tout le monde est d'accord sûr
il faut les imposer
eux ils le savent ils sont pas non plus
il se cache pas derrière leur petit ils
le savent ils savent aussi ici vont
simplement pour l'instant actuellement
on n'a pas les instruments vous le faire
on y réfléchit on a une taille qui est
là qui a les qualités de ses défauts ou
les défauts de ses qualités
le serbe preuve par l'absurde que le
repli sur soi des natios tous à nous
nous nous rend
nous rend totalement paralysé qua non ça
nous paralyser en même temps vous l'avez
vous avez vu la réponse de tram qui
s'est pas fait attardée et c'était si
vous faites ça en cavalier seul
moi je vous mets des rétorsions et ça va
se terminer à l'om s'estimant c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça et tu sais c'est
un peu c'est un peu le risque c'est
qu'en fait on est vraiment tellement
interdépendants que on à ces risques de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce où
on va faire un règlement entre état et
on va voir comment comment on s'organise
et on a ce risque là à être tout seul
jeudi qu'elle a les qualités de ses
défauts c'est qu'elle met à elle jette
un pavé dans la mare
sur qui paie pour ça aussi c'est je
pense fait pour cesser je pense fait
pour ça mais ça c'est induit quelque
chose qui n'a pas sa place en droit en
tout cas c'est la notion de morale nous
la morale de ce nom là n'est pas la
morale ccc ccc extrêmement c'est quelque
chose que tel que proposé par bruno le
maire ne rapporterait rien si un
compromis de 500 millions par an nous on
a fait les calculs avec notre étude si
sapiens et ça rapporte 49 millions par
an et paradoxalement à l'orangé rouge la
porter à 100 milliards de déficit c'est
bon par contre il ya ce qui est assez
amusant c'est que le plus gros client ce
sera le site impots.gouv.fr qui sera
touchée par la taxe gaffe à la drôle
c'est assez marrant non
là vous avez bien fait de rappelé à ses
contours du gaf a non ça se limite pas à
google apple facebook et sa touche croix
et amazon 150 entreprises
voilà parce qu'on a l'impression que ça
touche que c'est très grandes oeuvres
oui mais attention il des entreprises
françaises la gare notamment éviter
toute personne qui intervient par un
portail numérique tombent sous le coup
de cette taxe si elle réalise plus de
voeux à 500 millions de chiffres au
mondial et 25 millions et 25 millions
france donc à partir du mans vous avez
c'est ce double cette double clé
d'entrée vous rentrez dedans vous êtes
une
une entreprise du numérique et vous
intervenez pas seulement en france mais
à l'étranger vous êtes dedans corps en
un mois j'ai le sentiment du coup à
vouloir être la locomotive on peut aussi
terminer comme étant de bon ton moi ça
sera un petit peu moins produits tous et
complète d'argent il nous reste deux
minutes
donc on va aller très vite mais 350
millions ces deux coups froid annuel du
sénat
c'est trop oui j'ai pris le train du
luxembourg gagnerez beaucoup d'heures de
vaisseau fait partie du budget du sénat
c'est une dépense raison pour graver de
ce budget supprimer le sénat mais je
suis absolument contre c'est peut-être
aussi ma non formés savent parler parce
que c'est vrai que dans la sphère
benalla voilà ils ont les héros traduit
et deux très proches collaborateurs est
important du président de la république
la justice et donc repose au fond cette
question internet composé déjà du temps
de 12 faut-il modifier et réformer ou
suppriment il s'est alors modifié
évoluer se poser des questions faire des
associations avec des sénateurs des
citoyens avec le cesu et c'est pourquoi
pas mais ne pas supprimer le sénat bien
évidemment c'est un contre-pouvoir
indispensable et c'est aussi une
assemblée d'élus
ce sont des sages en fait et sa peine
pour raisons aussi bien que les
terribles 6,6 à 6 et 6 1 nous
franchement non gens n'ont pas annoncé
une défense des territoires alors on est
peut-être bien lotis on est peut-être
bien lotis mais c'est vrai qu'on a
particulièrement un président de ces
nains qui incarne la défense des
territoires
une anecdote d'ailleurs c'est très
amusant parce que je me rappelle d'un
jour où j'avais rendez vous avec avec
lui et gérard larcher voit à l'écran et
donc il est venu il m'a dit excusez moi
d'être en retard et je le vois arriver
avec ces bottes sont tirés et c est
jeudi
là vraiment président ont représenté
vraiment les territoires donc les
collectivités territoriales mais ça
représente pas le territoire c'est ça
qui me gêne
l'égalité n'est pas si on vous présente
pas les français il ya même de parité il
ya un problème d'âge également après je
suis complètement d'accord sur les sur
les compétences
qui sont qui sont exceptionnelles et
quant à la sphère benalla mon jeu tu est
constitutionnalisée plus + qualit mois
mais en dessous qu'on s'arrête
pardon mais la prochaine fois on part
avec grand plaisir des griots merci
infiniment ça fait m merci beaucoup à la
médina
merci c'est coralie de dieu merci
beaucoup pour votre éclairage notamment
alors sur les gars fonde appris plein de
choses
merci à toutes les 4 et à très vite pour
un nouveau pas fait j'espère que vous
revenez très vite
[Musique]